so last night guess what the late-night
errs had to say
now I come from from a place where we
don't have shootings at this frequency
so it's hard for me to fathom is that
the best plan DC has for dealing with
gun violence when there's a shooting we
just pray for a miracle I'm sorry that
we live in a world where there are
people who will put a gun before your
lives Congress can be heroes by doing
literally anything universal background
checks or come up with a better answer
and force Obama's executive order that
denied mentally ill gun purchases or a
better answer reinstate the assault
weapons ban or come up with a better
answer anything but nothing doing
nothing is cowardice now I try to come
up with a similar montage about the
4,300 shooting victims in Chicago last
year no luck
and here I thought this was about guns
but last night was all about unison
people claimed gun control talk is being
silenced this is silence sorry
I don't blame them at all and the
circles that they run in such outrage is
required and they mean it so what do
they have in mind specifically besides
do something do anything Colbert at
least he had suggestions but would they
have stopped this fiend but I get it I
throw the kitchen sink at terrorism a
sentiment mocked many times by these
very same people but unlike them I'm a
little flexible sure let's ban bumps
talks it would make me feel better
though I'm not sure it would help
because I think people will make their
own you can make your own guns now and
should that matter
according to Reason magazine from 1992
to 2014 the number of US civilian
firearms have increased by 50% while the
murder rate has dropped by more than
half think about that that's amazing
so more guns doesn't equal more death
but still the media focuses on the gun
especially early on before all is known
why is that my theory is that you focus
on
a weapon allows you to spread some blame
on two people that you already dislike
gun owners Republicans Trump voters
sometimes it feels like a class thing
remember that CBS lawyer saying she had
no sympathy for the victims because they
were gun loving wreaths uh glycans she
got fired and for what saying what she
thought her friends wanted to hear so
one there's no question when you watch
the the the late-night comedians their
sentiment is heartfelt but when you
listen to them the suggestions I don't
believe could have stopped this guy for
example
he wasn't mentally ill the that he's
never he has no criminal records on the
background check and he might it sounds
like he modified the gun which is
illegal so in this case in a lot of
these cases I believe these culprits are
so thorough and thinks think things out
so comprehensively that they are
unstoppable these are the people that
get through does that make sense sir no
I make sense and not you know I'm struck
by I was thinking about this because you
and I argue over guns yeah and I was
looking at the polling numbers and what
struck me on the polling numbers was
that Republicans generally think that
whatever you do is not going to make
that big a difference it's not gonna
stop the next case right and I think the
way for people like you and me to have a
conversation is to think in terms of
well what's realistic what could be done
yeah I don't know that it would have
stopped this guy cuz it seems like this
guy put a lot of planning into it - but
what would stop the next one okay and so
what I came away with from looking at
the polling numbers was that it's almost
universal it's like ninety percent of
Americans think we should have
background checks private and public
sales of guns people think we shouldn't
allow military-style weaponry to be sold
now that should be limited right people
also think that if you've got a mental
issue and it's known to the government
yeah that they should give that
information to ATF so they won't sell
you a gun right people so there are
these steps but guess what Greg I mean
you know that when people think about
the politics here I think Republicans
are so locked in with the NRA and Oreos
big trump back or their big backers
the Republican Party in general that
people think you know it's just you
can't get by the NRA you can't make the
case right now they're the big bill in
Congress right now is about silencers
yeah and when Steve Scalise the
congressman was shot they pulled it back
for the moment now they pulled it back
again after this one well gee you think
well why would Republicans be doing that
at a moment when so many people in the
country are concerned about gun violence
but that's where we are
I guess cuz the suppressor argument had
nothing to do with this because it
wouldn't have had an effect as far as I
can tell a lot of these things sound
good
but they don't have an effect Jesse and
that's the more you read about it it's
kind of amazing when you see places that
have very strict gun control like
Chicago doesn't or Baltimore doesn't do
a damn bit of good
yeah well I don't like being lectured
about guns by the party that hatched
fast and furious wands so that's one
thing the other thing the silencer bill
that's fake news that was never going to
be on the table this week that was a lie
but there if there's common-sense
constitutional gun control or reform I'm
all ears let me hear it but as a matter
of fact there of all the shootings mass
shootings since 2012 none of them would
have been stopped by new proposed gun
laws and that was fact checked by The
Washington Post note Pinocchio's on that
that includes the Tennessee shooting
that includes San Bernardino that
includes Dylan roof so I'm still open to
what you were talking about these little
slide stops or the bump stocks and you
can buy a kit to make a semi-auto a
machine gun for 50 bucks and you can
watch the video maybe you look at
something like that but you also
mentioned in the mollow is a great
monologue that as gun ownership rates in
America have increased the homicide
rates have decreased and Chicago is a
great example of it stringent gun laws
and a dozen people get shot every
weekend so criminals will always find a
way to commit crimes that's why they're
criminals look machine guns are illegal
guy had a machine gun drugs are illegal
people use drugs prostitution is illegal
people still buy prostitutes when
there's tragedies politicians come over
and act like they have to do something
and a lot of the times what they do is
it's just useless so let's just get
together wait for the facts that
we'll decide what we need to do and then
we'll take a vote on it in Congress let
me just respond quickly okay I just
think when you have I think it's like
twelve thousand people a year die from
gun violence in the country yeah I think
if that was anything else and Greg's
always concerned he says number one
threat is terror if the terrorists were
killing twelve thousand people here in
the United States we would impose some
very strict argument because you know
what you're arguing but let me just say
of course I do listen if you live you
made the great point last night if you
live out in the suburbs or in the farm
or something like that and you have a
lot of property out there you have a
small biz you have a wife you have some
daughters how when you call 9-1-1 you
know how long that's going to take my
live in cities well yes they do but let
me just say most Americans live in
cities and secondly I want to feel safe
you talk about taking guns they don't
like it okay you know the there's an
interesting thing here I was talking to
John Lott this morning who was an expert
on guns and testified before Congress
and he testified before the Parliament
of Australia on guns seized it this may
be the first machine gun Act even though
it wasn't a machine gun but it was a it
was a it was a conversion right
meanwhile in France you've had four such
examples in 2015 and they have the
tightest gun control laws Kimberly but
they had four machine gun attacks in
there so the bans even there don't work
and there were machine guns that were in
the 70s as well in England so my point
is this that this stuff has been
happening in places where they have very
strict gun control laws or we have to
have more background checks well he did
all the background checks
he passed those he was able to purchase
these guns and also get some that are
illegal so there wasn't a
lack of a band in this situation that
could have prevented this horrific
tragedy so but the left wants right away
say well let's see what we can do and
chip away an eventual you know erosion
of the second Amendment right the Second
Amendment constitutional rights should
prevail and yes we should do a better
job of understanding and figuring out
how we can prevent these shootings not
just by the weaponry use but by the
person who is pulling the trigger what
motivates what feeds their darkness what
is it is it jihad is it mental illness
are we doing enough about that in terms
of identifying people who might have
problems are we seeing and saying
something as everyone's been encouraged
to across this country to try to prevent
these things to not be afraid to get
involved don't be on the sidelines of
life when you are the best possible eyes
and ears out there for law enforcement
and those that would try to you know
combat against terror attacks in the
United States you know anyway I was just
thinking though that in Scotland after
the kids were killed there and also in
Australia after they had a mass shooting
they imposed limits to reduce the easy
availability easy access to guns you
don't buy that at all look check out
Australia the illegal gun market is
unbelievable and they make their own
guns they be a biker but they haven't
had another kind of mass shooting but
they have that they've had an influx of
gun crime it's gone up and in England
when they when they had their buyback it
will they only had one year which
homicides actually went down he was
testing yeah Dana I gotta get you in
here well I just say that man always
tries to believe that especially in
America that you can legislate things
away and there's nothing that the
government can do to make people do the
right thing yeah this actually goes much
deeper than that and part of the thing
about Kimberly saying like if you see
something say something
we've seen this time and again with many
of these other cases like the neighbors
in the San Bernardino you know like well
we don't want to say anything also I
imagine that we probably will hear from
people that worked at the Mandalay Bay
like well you know in Vegas what happens
in Vegas stays in Vegas yeah nobody says
anymore he was a high roller we don't
whine in Jesus Oh
imaginable that you couldn't do it but I
just think that we tend to believe that
we can do more than what God can do and
we can't legislate our way to morality
yeah and one less than query into
someone's heart walk exactly one I'm not
a big gun guy
you know I don't own a gun but and if
someone's insane I don't want them
buying a weapon if they're crazy
obviously I want background checks so I
think we can agree on that all right
okay let's